yo what's up everybody prestigio
marriage if he was another Borderlands
the pre-sequel biggie i'm going to be
showing you in this video how to get the
longest good which is a new hyperion
legendary laser that came out in the
clap tastic voyage dlc i believe when
you shoot an enemy with it it will
ricochet to of enemies and yeah pretty
google i think it's an alright legendary
i haven't found out it to be too super
amazing but maybe other people would be
able to so you're going to want to head
to the overlook memory access location
and you're going to head as i kind of to
the most to the right section of the map
this is going to be dropped this
legendary will be dropped from the
mini-boss side boss tat earworm or
without your worm spin the spells a
little weirdly and you'll see right
there there's some of the note note
tentacles it is a a whoa it's a thresher
that's what it is it's a thresher that
plays music catching music at you and
this is first unlocked in the side quest
you can't stop the music as you see I'm
doing this I was actually able to hit
the legendary on my first time killing
this boss which was pretty cool so and
after you kill the boss the first time
for the mission it's a side mission you
get from claptraps consciousness you
will be able to come back here anytime
and kill it you actually have to kill it
multiple times in this mission however
if when you come back later you'll just
have to kill it just the once it is a
fairly easy however a lot of times we'll
go underground so you won't be able to
kill him during those times and Booya
you see the longest yard so guys hope
you enjoyed this video if you did make
sure you leave just any sort of support
checking my other videos I know it's
about it I'll catch you guys in other
videos and hope you have a good day p
step